[Music]
foreign
daily cancellation we have a viral video
from somebody on Tick Tock which is
being shared primarily by people on the
right who primarily find this person to
be stupid and her opinion's worthless
and that's generally the way that it
works with these Tick Tock videos of
course and very often the people are
stupid and their opinions are
effectively worthless but in this case I
think that there's um a little bit more
to be said about it so let's first watch
the clip
all I can ever think about is the fact
that this is not the way that life is
supposed to be the whole working your
life away just to have a little bit of
money a little bit of free time to do
things that you actually enjoy it's such
a waste of life and the older generation
will be the first to call my generation
lazy for saying things like that not
realizing that they're just a bunch of
capitalism in their brainwashed I hate
my stupid racist xenophobic ancestors
who set up this system that sucks for
everyone except for like the one percent
this stupid capitalist Society has made
it to where no one can do things for
themselves anymore because we've been
brought up to depend on everything
grocery stores restaurants on every
corner a convenience store on every
corner because we can't do anything for
ourselves and we have no Community all
we rely on is people who are getting
paid and overworked their whole lives to
get things that we need that's not
Community it's all nothing but a
capitalist hellscape that sucks the life
out of everyone
okay well she uh gets a few things wrong
here just a few starting most
importantly with the very common
misconception that that happiness means
having a lot of free time to do what you
want as she says now if that was true
then virtually no one who ever lived on
earth up until the Industrial Age at
least was happy
um because free time as she conceives it
is an extremely modern phenomenon I
doubt that our ancestors even had a word
for it you know because it didn't exist
people were not working nine to five
jobs uh they were not they were not busy
in the way that we think of busyness
because we think of busyness as
something that's uh loud and Fast
Business uh you know it's it's busyness
is is work assigned to you by your job
it's text messages coming in and phone
calls and driving around to different
places you know we talk about being busy
that's what we mean and that kind of
busy
um didn't exist for most people who've
ever lived on the planet but they did
have work they had to work to survive
their lives were built on and around
work
there would not have been a day that
went by without work
we think of free time as time without
any kind of work at all time dedicated
to total and complete Leisure that's
free time to us free time is sitting on
the couch for hours ordering food on
doordash relaxing in a very sedentary
position
um some people spend days at a time like
this
you don't have any kids then they'll say
you're in your whole weekend could be
like that
but historically unless you were like a
pharaoh or a Roman Emperor or something
that kind of leisure that kind of free
time was not on the menu
indeed this kind of free time is an
invention
of our modern Western capitalist system
it's what it's what has made it possible
for people to spend hours and days at a
time doing nothing in a state of
complete Leisure avoiding nearly all
forms of work even the most menial kinds
she wants free time
but she hates the thing that gives her
free time
and even though she already certainly
has lots of free time she's not happy
which tells us that having free time
that is the avoidance of work
is not in and of itself a recipe for
happiness if anything
um being you know having too much free
time and avoiding work too much I think
our modern experience would testify is a
recipe for unhappiness
she's also wrong of course in her hatred
of our ancestors
to hate your own ancestors it's to be a
branch that curses the roots of the tree
that you're attached to
you would not have your existence at all
without your ancestors you would have
neither the positives nor the negatives
you would have nothing and be nothing
and as it happens in the case of this
girl and all the rest of us
we can thank our ancestors for many more
positives than negatives
as we already established all the things
that she has and supposedly likes and
wants more of free time Leisure Etc she
only has because of the work Innovation
and sacrifice of the ancestors whose
Graves she now spits on
and most of the things that she doesn't
want and complains about work hardship
she would have that no matter what
choices her ancestors made given that
these are fundamental realities of human
existence
you know there is no economic system
that can get you off the hook on those
things
people are raving about genucel products
for example you might remember Jacob the
PA for my YouTube series where I was
forced to play video games I played
against Jacob in a game of Mario uh
rather Mortal Kombat and I completely
annihilated him well I ran into Jacob in
the hall the other day and I was taken
aback by how sickly and tired he looked
I'm obviously an incredibly caring
person so of course I asked if he was
okay thinking maybe he still hasn't
recovered from the complete
embarrassment of a middle-aged man
beating him well turns out Jacob just
hasn't been sleeping at all over the
last few days because he's been binge
playing the new Star Wars game that came
out now I was not only repulsed by his
face but also repulsed by him completely
by everything about him and utter
disgrace and unfortunately I can't cure
all the things that ail him but I can at
least cure the disgusting hideous
appearance of his face with genucel
nothing works like genus all it's a
family recipe that's been perfected over
20 years Jenny cell promises immediate
effects you'll see results in 12 hours
guaranteed or your money back Jacob did
indeed see a meteor results and he
couldn't be happier at least so I uh so
I hear since he's no longer allowed to
be in my presence but I hear that he's a
slightly less repulsive at this point if
you don't want to look disgusting try
genucel's most popular package for 70
off at genucel.com Welsh all orders are
upgraded to free shipping and every
subscription order includes a
complimentary spring spa box with free
spa Essentials go to genyourself.com
Welsh
but she's not wrong about everything
um she makes the point and it's a
profound one
that many people in modern society are
effectively helpless
they cannot do anything for themselves
they have no skills they have no
capacity to be self-sufficient
and even those who are most skilled and
most self-sufficient still rely heavily
on giant institutions and corporations
to provide them with so many things and
while this is all happening we've also
become more isolated less Community
focused we don't even many of us know
our neighbors who live next door the
social experience has migrated online
into our phones behind the screen where
we can connect with people but that
connection is always limited by the
technology that facilitates it and
nothing feels exactly real
she seems to have noticed all of this
and it's good that she's noticed it
but the next step for anyone who notices
this problem
is to do something about it
and doing something about it doesn't
mean going on social media to rant about
the evils of capitalism it means
changing this dynamic in your own life
um here's the thing modern society
does not make it impossible to develop
skills it doesn't make it impossible to
find Community it doesn't make it
impossible to find meaning and purpose
in life instead what it does is that it
makes it possible
to not do those things
which is really what she's complaining
about
modern society gives us the option of
doing next to nothing developing those
skills remaining effectively isolated
coasting by and yet still surviving
this was never an option historically
because historically if you had no
skills you would simply die
if you didn't find a community in a
support system you'd probably just die
life required certain things that it no
longer requires the option to Coast to
live a low effort life has been opened
to us it is a door that we can walk
through and many people do
I mean think about this for a moment
we obviously don't need to know how to
kill catch or grow our own food and that
work that's work that most people on
earth have had to do through history but
but most of us Escape that burden
completely and it's been that way
basically since the Industrial Age
kicked into full gear but these days we
don't even need to know how to cook or
prepare our food
we can live without ever growing killing
catching or cooking our own food
and many people do live this way
so you could live alone and survive for
decades and decades to a ripe old age
without having the slightest clue how to
do anything with the food that you have
but chew it and swallow it
that is the degree of removal the depths
of laziness that we can choose
but we don't have to there are other
ways to live
but you have to choose those ways
and you have to essentially make your
life more difficult on purpose
so if you want to have a more direct
relationship with the food that you eat
and you decide
you know what I'm going to learn how to
cook I'm going to learn how to cook from
scratch I'm going to start and have a
garden I'm gonna grow my own vegetables
and all that you can do all that it's a
great thing to do but it's more
difficult and so it and you don't need
to
so anyone who's ever had a garden and
and gone through this and the hassle of
it you can have moments where you think
like why am I doing this I can just go
to Kroger down the street and get all
this stuff
but then if you do that and you live
that way then you end up like like this
girl talking about how well it's like no
I don't know how to do anything and it's
everything's being handed to me and it
feels like there's no point
so yeah you can go the other way but you
are making your you are you are creating
work for yourself and you're creating
hardship
um
and you have to be willing to do that
and you have to be you have to be
willing to live intentionally
while having the discipline to stay on
that path even as easier ones or at
least ones with less resistance are
available to you
you can develop skills you can learn to
to care for yourself to a great extent
you can even form families and
communities all of this is possible
modern society offers a certain way to
live a way that's easy but empty
and we can take it up on that offer or
not you don't have to be miserable or
alone or helpless it's not a requirement
it's an item on the menu
it may be the most popular item
and maybe the one that the restaurant is
always pushing on us but it's not the
only one
the others just take discipline and
effort
which is a price that many people
including this girl at this point don't
want to pay
and that is why she is still ultimately
Unfortunately today canceled that'll do
it for uh this portion shows move over
to members block you can become a member
today by using Code wall should check
out for two months free on all annual
plans hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed